Seoul has ordered the evacuation of an
island after North Korea launched
multiple ballistic missiles into the sea
the South Korean military said it was
the first time a missile from the north
fell so close to its territorial Waters
it follows a statement from Pyongyang
that the U.S and South Korea would pay a
terrible price should they decide to
attack the north Rob McBride is joining
us from Seoul so tell us about this
launch Robin how significant it was
yeah this was a flurry of missiles all
being launched at early Wednesday at
least 10 missiles we understand being
fired into these Seas surrounding the
Korean Peninsula now at least three of
these were short-range ballistic
missiles these are the types of missiles
that there's been an unprecedented
launching of these missiles since the
start of this year but significantly one
of these missiles was fired on a more
southerly route and in fact in the
direction of this is a very small
isolated uh South Korean islands in the
Seas between the Korean Peninsula and
Japan when it was detected flying
towards that Island they actually
sounded the air raid sirens there now
that's the first time people can
remember the air raid sirens ever being
sounded so it is a significant um
development the missile fell far short
of that island but again significantly
it fell south of the de facto Maritime
border between North and South about 2
26 kilometers South again that's another
first there hasn't been a missile fired
below that line beforehand this all
comes of course as the South Koreans and
the U.S allies conduct a large-scale
military exercises there are air drills
going on at the moment involving scores
of warplanes at the the kind of
exercises which we've seen resumed this
year after a several year Hiatus it
always angers the North and always
causes a strong response in fact
statements issued overnight condemning
these exercises uh have won the U.S and
the South Koreans that if they should
ever attack then they will pay according
to the North Koreans the most terrible
price in history so do we expect the
South Koreans to respond
they are sharing seeing this as a very
serious escalation uh Yun Suk Yol the
country's president has chaired a
meeting of the National Security Council
which they uh often do hold once there
has been some sort of action from the
north but he's come out with some very
strong language saying it's the first
time confirming it's the first time that
a missile has traveled south of the
division line since the division of the
peninsula saying this is tantamount he
says to a violation of our territory and
giving instructions to his
administration to make sure that the
North Korea pays a clear price there
have been other escalations in recent
weeks a few weeks ago again in response
to large-scale military joint exercises
the north carried out its own artillery
drills firing shells that fell within a
buffer zone that North and South Korea
agreed should they should not carry out
any exercises this was under an
agreement back in 2018 when relations
were far a better than they are now to
say the least and there is in the
background of course still the
continuing threat of continuing
expectation that North Korea might
resume for the first time in five years
it's nuclear testing and carry out a
seventh nuclear test all right thank you
so much Rob McBride for that update from
Seoul